Filmmaker/Writer/Comic Joe Wilson: For me it was always about the work. I
really...you know...I really loved it and I
wish I could have done it more but I
didn't.
Film Courage: How long have you been in Los Angeles? Joe Wilson: 22
years. Film Courage: And in a couple of months or a month...?
Joe:  In a couple of months I'm leaving forever not
by choice but some family members need
some help and my wife and I are gonna be
that help so leaving Los Angeles
it's the place I've lived the longest
actually my whole life. Film Courage: So how does that
feel to you do you is it sort of like
you're seeing those years flip by and
your mind like a TV show like it's ... Joe: it is
a combination of regret and and kind of
the realization that maybe things not
working out for me in the entertainment
industry maybe was for the best because
I think the timing of how if I if the
success came the way I thought it was
going to come at the time that I thought
it was going to come when spec sales
were huge and people made money fast I I
guess I I feel like I've just gone
through like the longest training
program anybody could ever go through to
learn how to do a bunch of shit I didn't
know how to direct or write or act or do
stand-up the way I do now from having
done it sitting down to write a book
having done all these different things
made the writing easier and better room
and all that stuff because I've been
doing it I you know I I wanted to come
here and be successful and buy my wife a
house didn't happen
so when things don't work out the way
you want and you improvise adapt and
overcome
and that's what I'm gonna do moving to
Albany New York which is not a
entertainment capital that I know of but
locations will be easier to get I do
have a line on actors play short is
something I can continue doing graphic
novel as I don't know how many more
issues in it I guess I had a lot of fun
I met a lot of people some of it was not
fun but I guess overall I wouldn't have
done any other way cuz I had to know
like I had to know what was gonna happen
she said regrets earlier oh yeah what
were their regrets oh good
too many to number I guess I should have
tolerated some fools more and yeah a
bunch of stuff but aren't you glad that
it forgive me I don't know where you
wanted before you went to Boston we're
still ok but were you still in yeah what
if you had stayed in upstate New York
and we're gone back I don't know you
know what were your travel line was and
you worked for a company and they pushed
you out the door because they're hiring
people from oh sure somewhere else or
they're closing that plant or something
so what I've essentially happened to the
company that I was working for in Boston
I was very lucky that the company I had
a day job with in Boston had a company
out here so when I I said I'm moving to
Los Angeles if you guys want me that's
where I'm gonna be and they were like
you can work in the other company's
office for Boston so I had a job that I
flew with so that was great and then
they pulled the plug on the company
fired everybody
well once I got out here um but what was
the question so I guess the question is
what if you hadn't come here wouldn't
you be more regretful for had not
because you're still with your wife oh
yeah no we're not trying to some people
don't
oh yeah I'm I know people have died you
know in pursuit of this some people died
from suicide some people died from drug
overdose some people died from lifestyle
you might say and I guess I guess what I
didn't know and there's no way you
really couldn't know like I did stuff in
Boston and he you know was done live
there's no you know this video of it but
most the time it was like it was theater
it was something that was done for a
live audience and that's what it was
meant to do and then when it was over it
and it and that was it it didn't exist
anymore except for in the minds of the
people who saw it I've heard from people
who remember the stuff I did in the 90s
when I was in Boston and performance art
stuff installation art and like all that
stuff is gone none of it exists anymore
but they remember it and you know if you
make a movie and it's successful and
when people see it and they'll remember
it sometimes movies become apart
people's lives they buy the DVD they
watch it on a regular basis something
out in the background it's the movie
they go to when they're feeling shitty
that is something I sort of got to
experience with vampire Moe the you know
I did have people contact me who said
that they you know life wasn't great and
they were kind of down
and they enjoyed the humor and the
characters in the story in it and it
gave them some place to go for a while
and that's why I feel like to some
degree storytelling is a service you are
in service of other people's stories are
for other people and that's who you're
creating for I mean you could create for
yourself but if they don't see it then
it doesn't exist what do you think that
you should have tried more of or maybe
maybe there's nothing you know I've
changed directions a bunch of times when
things weren't going right I'm like you
know when things with acting and
stand-up weren't going great and I was
looking at writing screenwriting and I
hadn't written anything and I'm like man
do I have a learning curve and I'm like
I gotta back off everything else take
classes really focus on on screenwriting
and and learn everything that I can
about it I never lost the question again
what what do you think that maybe you
should have tried oh I guess I probably
should have mm I think I should have
kept doing stand-up I think I could have
should have kept spreading myself out
then the way I was and find finding ways
to deal with that chaos which I enjoyed
to some degree but the more I met a lot
more people doing stand-up and when
you're a writer and you meet less people
because you're at home reading and I was
in a few writers groups and there were
always a nightmare I just it was almost
like competitive notes like oh yeah you
didn't like my screenplay way to like
give you notes on yours it was garb
I remember one screenplay that this guy
wrote and had very specific terminology
to the x-games to all these special
things you do on a skateboard on a BMX
bike and all this stuff and I'm reading
it and I'm like yeah I don't know what
any of this is and he's like well that's
the language that they use does the
thing I'm like yeah but what does that
mean what is they what do they do well
all you have to do is say that and
people know what it is yeah but the
person that the reading the at the
studio the agent they're not gonna know
this oh I'm sorry I'm telling you
information you don't want to hear I can
oh so this isn't feedback you just want
to be you wouldn't you just want to be
told this is good you don't want to make
it better you just want to so then and
then when it was time for mice for my
spring play to be routed he just was
like anything he could find and and you
you know I know what good feedback is
impede back and that was revenge
feedback what advice would you give to
someone else leaving Los Angeles hmm I
wouldn't give them any advice I guess
yeah I kind of sometimes advice is just
someone else's version of the way they
think things should work and and it's
just it's just another obstacle it's
just it's a it's a your expectation is
being managed by someone else's
experience and their experience isn't
necessarily what's going to be your
experience so the advice has no value
because they're well the way I did it
well yeah well the way you did it is and
and that was what I think one of my
problems was that I was trying to I saw
how other people made it and I was
trying to do it the way they did it I
was okay so he do this and he win a
contest then you get a manager and then
you go out take script out and then you
sell it and
there's a million ways careers happen
and don't make them mistake I did of
sort of telling your story you're like
well this is gonna happen then I'm gonna
do this this and this and this and
that's the way it's gonna be
and then when it's not oh I did
something wrong I guess I'm the problem
so I got to change the plan
so in irony this this and this and all
right that's not working oh my god it I
I enjoyed less of it I missed out on a
lot because I was working so hard to try
to make it what did you miss out on Oh
birthdays vacations seeing the outside
world friendships Allah
can always sit in one chair at a time
what does success look like to you I
don't know anymore actually that is a
good question
nothing to do with the entertainment
industry
well you'll still be able to make
stories oh yeah and and now you might
have a pool of people that oh sure
aren't going to be you know there's
gonna be access to talent up there as
well yeah and maybe something new will
come from it and it'll be a new
definition of because I think coming
being here
we're so clouded by not the middle-class
version of success oh but this like
astronomical thing that I don't even
know if those people are happy we don't
know that we don't know if that's have
met a lot of people who were wealthy and
successful and miserable I remember
talking to somebody who has working on a
basic-cable show and a network show at
the same time and they were complaining
that the basic cable show didn't send a
driver and then the network show did it
was you know why doesn't the basic cable
show send the driver and I was just like
I'm in the back my mind going you know
how many fucking people would like to
have that fucking problem not having the
basic cable show send a driver oh you
have to drive yourself to your job that
you get poor you it break in my heart
it's like listen to people who like
social media experts who complain about
traveling they're like oh my god it's so
hard to travel from conference to
conference and miss flights and all the
rest of it really get up on a roof and
do some roofing in August and Los
Angeles get the smell of tar up in your
nose and then tell me how hard it is
again to sit in an airport really is it
really that hard to sit in an airport
sorry sorry you have to sit so long
sorry that's such hard work for you
sorry you're not at the hotel where
you're supposed to be at the right time
again get on a fucking roof and fucking
August with the smell of tar in your
nose and tell me again how hard it is
that you work writing is not hard none
of this shit is hard none of this shit
is roofing in August in Los Angeles any
time you think you're working hard think
oh you know and I'm not on a roof in 95
degrees with tar up my nose that's hard
work
all the rest of this you know I worked
hard but it didn't do roofing for the
last 22 years you know I was indoors it
was not hard work I've seen hard work
and then about my hard work I've done
hard work none of this is hard work
hard work is a bunch of 18-hour days on
set they have to day after day that is
hard work hard work gaffers do hard work
electricians to our door Carver
distantly actor is less so
directors less so that's why I never
wanted to be a video village director I
never wanted to be the guy sitting
looking at fucking monitors and barking
shit from a chair I wanted to be holding
a camera and I wanted to be right in
there were the actors because that's
where it is happening and if I didn't
know how to run a camera then I couldn't
have done that so I learned how to run a
camera so I can do that and I'm a better
director because I run camera because
I'm there I'm with the actor the actors
looking at me the director who's
operating the camera that's pointing at
them completely different experience and
the guy over in the corner who's barking
stuff back or gets up walks over says of
them box back I just y'all cut good
anything all right
again go I can shoot ten pages in four
hours door-to-door in and out done it
every time every episode of play sure
which was four hours rehearse the actors
for two hours a week before bring him in
we walk into Nic's at four o'clock we
set up lights we eat dinner we shoot we
close it up 9:00 9:30 we're gone for
five hours
oh you don't need an 18-hour day and you
don't need a giant crew
any thoughts on friendships in LA
partnerships
friendships in Los Angeles are sometimes
friendships are based on projects
there's a lot of project friendships
like you're working on a project and
every reason friends and you know each
other forever and the project is to
never see each other again that's pretty
common and then you're right it's like
co-worker friendships it's not kind of
thing I think it is harder to have or at
least it was
I found it harder to have more
meaningful friendships just at the the
pace of everything that was going and
everyone's so worried about their career
and and who's got what who's doing what
and the next thing that it it didn't
allow for a lot of deeper friendships I
felt but some of that's means and some
of those la so is it about the work for
me it was always about the work I really
you know I really loved and I wish I
could have done it more but I didn't
what's the thing you're most proud of
nothing that's on screen yeah I don't
think um I think I'm more proud of what
I what I knew that I got through it
I guess not any specific work it sort of
e all of it all those classes workshops
graders groups meetings wit managers and
contests oh I could have made a
lot more money doing something else but
it wasn't I moved out of here for the
money because I was doing you know the
nonprofit art thing in Boston and
there's something about the there's
something about making art when you know
it's not gonna make you any money that
is different when you know I mean people
oh I paint didn't I put up in the
gallery and people pay me thousands of
dollars yeah most painters don't have
that most painters are they got a lot of
paintings and that haven't sold can I
think when I did an installation that
had 27 TVs in it and things were run by
motion detectors and the ravit see ours
and slide projectors and took up a giant
room and it took me 50 hours to put it
up and I had help and I was in that
gallery for a week and almost slept on
the floor one night it was there so long
and I knew I was gonna make a dime from
it knew it knew it cost me money to do
it wasn't gonna make a dime but I had to
do it I had to do it I had to make it I
it was the first thing I ever made it
was huge
and I showed it once I never showed it
in and that thing chain
just everything I didn't do that thing I
wouldn't be sitting here talking to you
right now because I know the Domino's
that went over because of that one thing
I make so when you make something that
is for commerce that is that as the goal
Commerce's the goal and it doesn't sell
then it's not a success and and that is
its business that is people don't get
paid if you don't make money art is you
know I got grants like a you know worked
at day jobs to pay for all the stuff so
I could have the time to make the art
and all that and the the reward was
seeing people go through it hearing from
people afterwards like that was enough
and when I started doing stand-up and
performance are dealing with doing a
little bit of touring with us with two
different shows that's one you know I
got a thing's got to get paid for you
know I got to pay for all this stuff so
this has to make at least this much
money to pay for this much stuff and if
I'm gonna get and if I'm gonna be a paid
it's got to be above these costs they
when you're out here in Los Angeles in
the entertainment industry you're not
making anything that has not made for
money that is the goal that's it's a
business you're not making art you're
making commerce you're making product
and yes there's some creativity in it
but if nobody wants it nobody wants and
nobody cares Wow
you've written a great screenplay but no
one will ever make that no one wants
there's lots of people who know I've
done definitely done a couple of those
but so the value of it is like
screenplays are not to be read there
maps for movies if they're not made into
movies them they're not then they don't
exist
they're nothing they're not there isn't
screenplays a literature there's people
sitting around a we write a good
screenplay yesterday so good it's
ridiculous
but the I think the thing with the
internet neighbors who have a response
to my work is similar to seeing human
beings have a response to my work in a
gallery and I started as a photographer
so it was just a picture on a wall or
read in front of them or in a newspaper
magazine and then when it was
installation I surrounded the viewer
sound light images physical objects a
structure that changed the space and
then I started doing performance art
because the same thing I could control I
they were sitting there I was sitting
here and I could create something that
we could all that could have we could it
could happen together and you would
experience it your way and we're all
here together this is what's happening
and yeah you paid a ticket to get in
here but it's barely gonna cover the
cost of doing this fucking show that is
very similar to when I make shorts and I
put them online and I hear from people
who who saw it's the value
the value is the experience that you're
creating for someone else in whatever
media so you know stand-up comedy your
job is to make people laugh so that's
your job if you're telling somebody a
story
it's a funny story not a funny story it
has to keep them amused and engaged and
interested and when it's art I think you
don't think exactly the same way I think
it's I think it is a little more of the
I'm making art and you're gonna see it
and the relationships I think different
a little bit yeah so yeah just thinking
of like Cindy Sherman yeah you know and
and whether it mean I know she got a lot
of criticism for some of the work that
she did but I just found her so
fascinating yeah yeah just just
especially the time in history that she
was doing her work compared to now when
everyone's taking selfies left and right
right that's such a weird and also just
the reality that people are more
comfortable in front of lenses there's
going to be entire generations now that
have no problem being from another
camera or just living for life in front
of the camera not even being able to
enjoy an event you're having to show
having to document it yep selfie museums
and that's all cool that's great but at
some point you're not really in reality
though right people are going in movies
and they're texting during the movie why
would you pay for a ticket mm-hmm is it
for the air-conditioning and somewhere
to sit right and then and and and that's
what makes going to the movies are
attractive to people like it has to be
Marvel it has to be loud and action so
everyone's attention is on the screen
and not on the other screen they have in
their pocket and if the movies not good
enough to keep your attention from
texting then maybe it's the movie
or maybe we need more it's like a drug
and so well it's not enough to just have
good dialogue anymore a great
interesting scene between two people
we'd become too desensitized to it I
don't know if all of us have but I think
they're definitely you know there's it's
like pop music pop music is inherently
shitty music not all of it but a lot of
it except for the song pop music
actually so much so pop music is you
know it's it's uh it's short it's catchy
it's got some part that you can sing
along with or hum along with or whatever
it's got some little chorus hook thing
in it someone's been jilted yeah exactly
and I think it's I think it's the same
to some degree with with movies feder
Popular's that you know it's just men
does this little thing that you've seen
it comes and goes and and that's it it's
very and then there's other movies that
maybe have a bigger impact I don't know
I really think about the audience
audience is now so many people are
watching stuff alone you know with a
laptop or on their phone or you know if
you're on a plane
everyone's watching a movie on something
and that is the more normal behavior now
then to have the sort of communal
experience of a theater where you you're
all laughing at once or you're all
jumping at once and now it's just you
and I think as a storyteller I'm like
now I never think about a theater I
never think about a group of people
watching I always think about one person
yeah I never think about a group I used
to think about groups of people when I
was writing and now I think about a lone
person especially writing the book I
definitely think about one person
because that is the only way it works
but even with yeah even with the other
stuff I would say that's true
you